today's show is brought to you by Square
cash
you guys know square cash square cash is
the best way to pay people honestly
understand me setting money is totally
free and fast and most payments can be
deposited directly to your bank account
in seconds it happens in seconds you
understand some of these some of these
other ones they don't do it in seconds
that it takes it takes like days but
this is fast download the free square
cash app for iPhone or Android now
[Music]
what's up my babies hey it's a
congratulations we're back and it's the
eleventh episode did you ever think we'd
do it I didn't know if we do it or not
but we did it um and I think that's
that's amazing now it's very interesting
that my producer chose to open up a
soda can right after we started
and you guys heard that cheese that was
him so it's very interesting they did
that even though he should have done it
right before but um it's all good and
you know I'm not upset um uh we were
just talking about I got this group text
message going on with actually my
producer here and another close friend
and a brother of mine and my actual
brother I know when you say a brother it
sounds like it's either somebody who you
love very very dearly or if I was a
racist white guy might be a black guy
yeah we have a brother we have a brother
in the text message chain but uh and we
were talking about my brother sent this
horrible horrible horrible horrible
funny Instagram video and I was very bad
and we watched it and we all got angry
and you guys do this with your friends
you know what I mean oh my God look at
this and then you love to hate it
so I was saying that I hated
it because it drives me nuts that people
think they're funny just because they
have Instagram and then do funny videos
and my brother and one of my other close
friends was saying that the worst part
about it were the people that think it's
funny and I I don't agree with that I
think it's bad that somebody thinks it's
funny but ultimately they were saying
that funny is whatever somebody thinks
it is which is very true if you think
something's funny it's funny um but I
was saying you it you got to take
responsibility in the it's disrespectful
basically like my mom says she's always
said Oh Chris you have such a good voice
you should sing and that makes me mad
what makes me mad is if then I believed
that and then started singing and then
was like yeah I'll just do a singing
career like if I all of a sudden but you
know besides doing comedy I would go on
Instagram or you know doesn't have to be
our Instagram but since we're talking
about it I'll go on Instagram and then
all of a sudden like do some singing
videos because I because it got in my
head that I have a good voice and I took
them seriously that's what what makes me
mad is that people don't have the filter
themselves to be like oh well a singing
like to be a singer is risk
it's so disrespectful to - for me to
think oh I'm gonna sing now because
these singers have been taking
years and years and years and years of
their lives and sacrificed relationships
marriages relationship with their kids
friendships and then for
somebody like me to come along and be
like I'm gonna sing now that's the most
disrespectful ever so don't do
comedy
if you don't do comedy that's mainly the
thing I'm not gonna sell
a house not a realtor not a realtor hey
if I walk up and down the block
and I say and I say hey you guys want to
buy a house people be like oh what you
don't earn you the comedian yeah yeah
yeah but right now I sell houses because
I
to today it doesn't work like that pay
your dues pay your dues did Lyndon then
then dude that's my PSA for today pay
your deuce
um yeah IIIi don't know but so that's
what we were talking about what do you
guys think you can tell me you can tell
me on the hashtag congratulations pot um
you can do that if you want and um by
the way as you noticed in the last
episode in the episode before that maybe
um yeah
got some sponsors and that's how it's
going to be that's how it's going to
be and sometimes people are
tweeting me now saying oh man dude don't
you suppose you know don't talk about
know you really sucks you got
you know you got to do sponsors you guys
do commercials in your hey my
question for you is why the did you
think I started doing this goddamn
podcast huh got serious question for you
why the do you think I
started to do this podcast huh what you
think it was to entertain you
you goddamn uh self-centered piece of
or was it to get that
scrilla was it to stack chips or was it
to make sure that your work day was
better for 40 minutes or was it to
literally back up the Brinks truck and
pile gouda into my garage this is how
life is don't tweet me oh man sucks you
got sponsors trying to back
the Brinks truck dude sorry you gotta
listen to 15 seconds of me hock in a
potato fast-forward it bye I gotta back
up the Brinks truck okay so if you start
hearing ads on my podcast which
by the way is free for you then just
know when you're hearing those ads I'm
hearing beep-beep-beep-beep cuz the
Brinks trucks backing up okay
so sit back relax listen all the
free okay stop complaining because
what you're doing is being and in Great
Neck now you got lots of problems of
course you got lots of problems that's
why you're somebody who takes to Twitter
and complains about commercials but I'm
busy piling up that blue cheese okay
yeah
this is why I do it dude this is why I
do it
so yeah allowed people oh man don't
spend that much time talking about it by
turn round yeah dude if you tweet about
how I shouldn't have commercials turn
round alright
speaking of turning round last time we
did a big thing about how United
you turn round and look what happened
dude
look what happened today a guy
got limp bodied dragged off a
commuter jet because he wouldn't give up
his seat now this is another thing we
were talking about in my text message
chain to it alright one of my close
friends was was pissing me off a great
deal
because he said the guy should have just
got up off the plane when security got
got on the plane
all right here's what happened if you
don't know what happened United the
piece-of-shit airline piece of
Airways boy Aires United
white my airline over
booked their flights because they always
do now that shouldn't be a thing period
don't over book don't sell something you
don't have hey dude
do you guys want to buy you guys want to
buy watches send me a bunch of money and
I'll send you the watches and then when
you send me the monies oh don't have
watches can't do that so legal all right
so these people are selling seats that
they don't have they don't have them
there's 200 seats on an airplane or
whatever and they sell 300 I
don't know what the they do but
don't do it all right now a lot easier
lines do that that's not cool but United
does it so much and we know that
because they're the worst piece of
airline run by cats okay now um they
overbooked and when they over booked you
hear this a lot on that over comm you'll
get some person who can barely
speak English that's like United answer
to say that they have over board they're
flying so we want to do is we would like
to offer a voucher for $25 some and the
hotel but you stay at the kitchen of
Doubletree Inn and you will be able to
leave in five days instead of right now
and everybody goes like this no and then
they say hello nobody took the bait so
what are we going to do is we're going
to sell the turnip by the voucher the
voucher we're adding the battery but not
by the way we're offering you money
we just given you a voucher so you can
take this shitty airline later but we
have changed it from $25 to $26 and
we're going to put you up a little bit
nicer we're not going to put you up in
the kitchen of the Doubletree we're
going to put you up in the
and right outside of the Sanji shop
we're going to put you right outside the
sandwich shop we're going to give you
free toothpaste and you get to leave in
four days now instead of it today and
instead of five days four days then when
no one takes that debate they're like
okay we basically going to you in
the ass and Troy off the plane bye
that's what happened what happened was
nobody took the vouchers and
then they got it by the way this was
already when they were on the plane and
then they got randomly selected for
people to get off the plane and one guy
wouldn't go so security came on and
took the guy off literally they
bashed his face against the
armrest and then dragged his limp body
off of the plane now that's awful and
that's a hundred percent obvious don't
bash a guy's face on the plane that's
pretty much how it goes and don't drag
someone off the plane that's pretty much
how it goes now here's the worst part
they needed the seats United needed the
seats for United staff to get to
another Airport now that's one of the
worst parts okay uh but now they my
point is offer more money until the guy
wants to get off the plane
you sold me some now I have it now
it's up to you to buy it back if
you want now I know there's a bunch of
fine print and but we don't live in
a world where people read the
fine print I know I'm starting
to sound like a little bit like Alex
Jones but dude don't you sell me
something I don't give a what the
fine print says it's mine okay you cheap
ass hair her airline
take you want it back give me more than
$35 they offered him $800 this
guy was a doctor trying to get back to
his patients on Monday and he couldn't
he said no
so security came out and dragged him off
now all that being said this guy who was
dragged off of the airplane was the
of the week okay he screamed he
screamed hey you grown man don't scream
don't scream because security came and
tried to take you off the plane
the guy scream like a look at the
video he went and then they dragged him
his limp he went limp
he went limp and they dragged him they
rolled him off like like it was like
like chicken like they just dragged him
oh my god he looked so my brother
took some screenshots and sent them to
me other guy I'm going to post them on
Twitter they're hilarious this
guy's in his 40s or 50s acting like a
victim which he was a victim but come on
bro pull your nuts down this guy
pull your nuts down dude and yo
don't I tell you one thing I wouldn't
got off that goddamn plane
there's no way I would have done
I'm gonna took it to Twitter or some
but man no dude make it worth my
while I don't know
everyone was sending me this cuz I
always talk about United and then
so everyone tweeted it to me and I
looked at it first thing in the morning
and the guy screamed like a and
how about those how women the
housewife women that were just like no
no hey shut the up
No ah you're so coddled you know I would
have been laughing my balls out
of my if that if I saw that ha
ha
you know what I would have done I would
have I have them this is what I
have this on my phone permit for things
like this I have the Mission Impossible
theme song and I would have played it on
my phone you would have heard it
the guy would have been like no no and
then I just would help
phone up in a wood one pink ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
and and it would you know I would have
played that you would have heard that on
the video if I was on the plane and that
would have been the best part
that's some guys trying to get
off the plane they couldn't get him off
the plane and that was the mission
impossible yeah Lily Lily Lily Lily when
I yank King King King King King King oh
man
with his limp body
[Music]
everyone's a victim but this guy
is gonna get money I hope this guy gets
money I hope United I hope this
guy's shoes United uh III want to sue
United for having it the distress of
having to see that video
United after that leggings
United forever
I'm not even complaining I'm just trying
to I'm just trying to give you
what's right also this is
a cult it's not a podcast man you and my
cult you understand you
understand um
Coachella is coming up and I want
everybody to not go so that's it I'm not
even going to spend a lot of time on
this I just feel like it's one of those
things man it's one of those things that
people just jump on because they jump on
and then stagecoach is a big thing two
of the people who are like yeah and nah
Coachella but we're gonna listen to
country hey hey this is the thing let's
be out in 107 degree weather where
people literally die just for being
there let's dress up in hot dumbest
outfits let's dance like morons around
people who are on Molly
on bands that are definitely terrible
that you can for sure listen to more
clearly if they just got them on iTunes
and listen to them in your car let's
be with 1 million people doing that now
all that is awful but then as if that's
not bad enough on a Coachella let's
replace that awful music with country
music the week later and go to
stagecoach now let me make something
very clear I talk in a lot of absolutes
and a lot of hyperboles because it's
funny do I really believe all of it I
don't know that's up for you to decide
but let's stop the comedy right now and
for four seconds while I say this let's
make it real if you like country you're
dumb back to comedy all right now I
don't care how you listening to it all
right I understand I you know I don't
care I don't care how you're listening
to it I don't give a I don't care
if you think it's funny I don't care if
you think it's good I don't care if you
think yeah I get it I get what it is but
still put it on
No get that person
turn around dude and then and then
people say to me but you haven't
listened to the good country yeah I have
what's the good country
what is it Hank Williams is that
what they say in 1940 RF fine that's it
him that's it he if you started
some and you made it
and then it turned into some
then fine but that's it you're not gonna
play me some I walked out
on him Brown I walked out on him Brown I
walked out on him Brown burned his
house down brown that's the
song if you're a woman and if
you're if you're a woman and country
that's your song if you're a guy
in country it's listen to music with me
in my car on the Hill while we
look at on the city I'm just a
country boy Brown suck
copious cucumbers dude you
ass we're listening in the back of a car
we're listening to music somebody else
wrote the song and then they sold it to
me Brown and then you're like yeah now
it's bad but you know it's still still
what this is ha ha
turn around dude
walked out on him Brown burn this
house down Brown only thing
unlock the batam was his dog Brown shut
up it's bad it's formulaic this bad
country music dude how Canadian is it to
like country music - dude I just I just
that don't impress me much how how I
love that that that song was the
beginning of when I was like what the
is going on when she's like so she
cuz here's why that song doesn't make
any sense cuz she says oh you're
a rocket scientist or whatever the
that don't impress me much
how how and then she says huh so she
comes up with all these extravagant
things that would absolutely impress you
if you'd never got a lobotomy if you
never were an absolute insane
person she says all these things like
huh so you finished school in four weeks
huh you can wash a car without using
soap and water is impressive no matter
what - I don't remember what the
examples were but huh you a bird
and now you gave birth to a human bird
hybrid that don't impress me much yet
does yet does okay so she comes up with
all these extravagant thing
you built a TV out of twine and
starbursts that don't impress her yet
does that's me scratching the record yet
does some you know what I want somebody
to do out there make the song and then
have it stop every time she says that
don't impress me much and then
put me in there and have it go like this
yet does somebody please do that I'll
crying laughing umm what's
that yeah oh oh yeah that's what she
says
so you're Brad Pitt huh dad don't yet
does who does Shania Twain marry by the
way anybody should probably married
Christian Bale so you're Brad
Pitt huh that oh the oh the biggest
movie star in the world doesn't impress
you much bye dude don't be a dick about
it don't be a don't put down
Brad Pitt Brad Pitt or that song as I
aren't kind of kind of stings so
here's what the this is make all
the examples you want but the last one
she says is this is what drives me
nuts
say you got a car dude hey start with
that one you that that's
actually not impressive sell you ate a
salad I mean what so you know what a
wall is what are you talking about she
starts off with the all the
so you took down bin Laden huh so you
learn how to resolve conflict without
using missiles and then so you saw a dog
you saw a dog once huh doesn't impress
you well no
having a car doesn't impress you but all
the other stuff does so don't end with
the car thing so then at the end of the
show
on all the women are like yeah
that doesn't start with the car thing
dude
start with the car thing then
get to Brad Pitt then get to the rocket
scientist and you won't have as many
women on board with you don't trick the
women do it don't trick the
women it does impress you I know what
you're doing Shania true Shania Twain I
know what you're doing all this
all this God I just
I'd like well I don't know how I got to
country oh yeah stagecoach dude
stagecoach got any of the excuse to wear
an outfit is what drives me nuts
if you like
I think 65% of these people are go when
I see people did you get your hunt on it
cuz I don't you hear these people talk
because I would never be around these
people but did you get your Coachella
outfit like it's a I got a
question oh you got a Coachella outfit
why do you have an outfit you're just
going outside to hang out around a bunch
of people uh oh yeah you got an
outfit why you got an outfit what is it
hey you gonna play hey what hey what
black box theater you going to
oh you're not going to Coachella you go
into a black box theater and you're
going to perform for me now you know I
got to tell you guys something about
this underwear I've been wearing and
it's me undies and it's it's actually
amazing now I know that uh you know I'm
like telling you about this because uh
it's a it's a it's an ad but I'm also
telling you that it's amazing underwear
it's actually the only underwear I wear
I have so many different pairs or all
different colors and they're very cool
and honestly store-bought underwear in
five packs it's just not good it's a rat
they rather they they come off at the
seams and I have something that's going
to change life for the better and it is
me undies now it's really soft dude it's
comically soft you put it on if you're
like what is this and it feels good and
it's delivered right to your door you
can have it delivered like it's pizza or
something so me and these are designed
in LA and they're made from this thing
called micro modal and
it's fabric that is actually three times
softer than cotton and guess what you
save time and money each month with a
monthly subscription so if you're ready
for a subscription do that and if you're
not it's okay you can still save and
that's because me undies is offering you
20% off of your first pair me Indies
dot-com congrat I'm sorry me Indies calm
/ congrats get 20% off your first pair
go ahead
me undies calm / Congrats
20% off your first pair me undies calm /
congrats square cache is honestly in my
opinion the best way and the only way to
pay people for stuff period it goes for
restaurants coffee with friends
splitting the tab whatever it doesn't
matter you can do you could pay the
Mafia that way if they want they have
them get the the app no extra gimmick
gimmicks no you understand me
that's how much passion I have about
this I'm saying in this ad such
it's just payments in your bank and done
that's it download the free square cash
app for iOS or Android now square cash
is better than the other guys I'm
telling you and you can and you can pay
the Russian mafia that way and then they
go like this
or thank you very much glad they
downloaded a squid cash app just like
you for square cash app for iOS or
Android Neal do that and that's on the
Apple App Store or the Google Play app
uh so um yeah remember what I said about
ads you think that you think that I'm
not going to do those yeah you got
another thing coming man
and by the way you're going to get that
too because it's good I'm only
going to do the good ones I think so far
I've only done the good ones uh so yeah
I was by the way I was um I was at the
did you hear that I just cracked my neck
I wonder if you heard that I was at
the I walked by a pet store recently and
because they were selling they were
selling not selling but they had like
dogs for adoption and like that but
they all
so I had like um so I guess it wasn't
pets oh I know what it was but it had
like all sorts of like as snakes
and hey where's a snake who is a
pet snake
who has a pet snake who has a
pet snake number one number two if you
want a pet snake you you don't walk by a
pet store and you're like huh you know I
bet a snake would be a good thing to
have and what if you left a house and
you were like going to get a coffee and
you walk by a pet store and you came
home with a snake and your wife was like
um it's over honestly I have two dogs
I want to punt them if I had a snake
what dude anyone who has a pet snake
deserves to get bitten by that snake for
sure uh and deserves to lose the snake
and then be like where's the snake in my
house and deserves to be terrified who
has a lizard who has a pet tarantula who
has bugs dude you get a dog you get a
dog you get a cat that's it you don't
get a snake all right
you know I don't get a snake cuz you get
a dog or a cat do you have a gerbil get
a snake have the snake eat the gerbil
then get rid of the snake that's how we
do that that's how we do that
do you have a
take B in India okay are you in Southern
California are you in Milwaukee move you
can't have a snake pet snake if you're
if you're in America I'll give a
very weird i watch this speaking of
animals I watched this documentary type
thing where like these violins this
Stradivari violins work some of them
cost like fifteen million dollars for a
violin like what kind of a guy do you
have to be that loves violence that
would pay fifteen million
dollars for a violent and I was learning
why the violins are so expensive and
it's because they were made while the
time of year in like the early 1900s I
think it was it wasn't really paying
attention because it was a documentary
about violins but um it was uh they were
saying that the width the the reason why
it was so expensive was because the
sound was so good when they were made
because the trees were growing really
slowly and the when the trees grow real
slow the wood is more is dense it's more
dense it's denser more dense more denser
I think anyway um so um they also were
made because these this guy was like
making a bunch of limited violins with
spider web
the the strings were made of like some
kind of spider silk which was like it
was like oh how bored are we as
the human race to be like to
have figured this out you know like
we've come such a long way we built
houses in great like that some guys like
let's use the dense wood we'll make the
violins and let's use to fight
to even figure out let's squeeze spiders
and make an instrument so they
they made these violins and in this you
time period of this year these few years
they were the best violin
ever now they go for like 50 they go for
millions of dollars and the thing is
they can't so they figured out that
these strings were really good because
of the the spider silk but you can't
farm spiders because they they're
territorial and if you put them all in
the amount of the guy was saying if you
put them all together then they'll kill
each other it'll be like a scene
from 300 until there is only enough
spiders that they have enough space to
live right so this one guy this
scientist scientists are just lunatic
decided to inject goat embryos with
spider silk genome and the then
the the the goats would reproduce and
then the goats would come out
and in their milk they would have spider
silk and they would produce
thousands of sounds dozens of uh
I don't say pounds you know whatever the
whatever the liquid the liquid one
in ounces or I don't know what it what
it was but of spider silk and then they
can make all these violins sounding
amazing Hey how bored are we as a human
race it just got even worse spiders like
we can't farm spiders hey dude that's
the end of that well we can't farm
spiders well okay I guess we're not
going to make the best sounding violins
that the common ear can't even list
English but some guy was like you know
I'm bored enough I bet I could make it
work with goats how bored do you have to
be how many episodes of chopped have you
seen to where you're like okay I'm gonna
try and have spider silk
injected in goats to see if goats can
produce spider silk
so violins can sound better that's a
sentence that came true because the guys
aw too many episodes of chopped junior'
dude before I decide how to make a
violin sound better with goat milk I've
seen everything on Amazon Hulu
crackle I dude I've seen everything on
crunchyroll ok I've seen everything on
iTunes I've seen everything on youtube
I've watched that Kevin Hart
comedy app that he tried to launch I've
seen every video on that I read
downloaded vine even though it's dead I
saw every vine video I went to Japan and
only saw the you know apps you
can get there and then and only then I
decided to make violin sound better with
goats how bored are we and by the way
everyone got cured from cancer AIDS and
also tuberculosis and polio everyone's
got all their limbs we've regenerated
everything the pair of paralyzed the
paralyzed people were paralyzed can now
walk again we've figured out a way to
restore hair growth and make tits bigger
naturally tighters and dick
bigger dicks bigger and then and only
then we decided to make violin sound
better with goats and spiders I mean
come on what are we doing dude what the
are we doing what are we doing
hey I got a question for that guy who
figured that out what you doing I want
to fly to that area wherever it is
definitely not in a city you know why
you know why you know it's not in a city
because you know what cities have things
to do
this guy was far away from lots of sex
far away from the internet and was like
oh I do
saw goats heard a violin and went ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
hey guess what
hey guess if the guy's 12 or 70 he's 70
you know why you know cuz he's bored his
dude oh man I watched this
documentary with my mouth open and my
dick out just cuz it's disrespectful I
gotta take my dick out for this can't
watch this show with my dick in
my pants because I have no respect for
it you know it's actually that's a joke
I really do have respect for some but I
don't give a what you do as long as
it's not hurting anybody and also you're
passionate about it dude I hope that guy
makes the most brilliant
violence of all time and they go for
millions and millions and millions of
dollars but also get some stuff to do
you made violence sound better with
goats and spiders you weird hey guy you
probably haven't had that much sex hey
guy amazing dude III don't know IIIi
don't know how it I don't know how it I
don't know I don't know how you do that
I don't know how you got the the the the
focus you know what else did they have
on the show I was watching that
what show was it by the way it was
called it's probably and then let
me go on Netflix to see what I watched
recently uh I love how they change they
keep changing the app icons by the way
so you never know what you're
looking for that's awesome when YouTube
turned white the app turned white and
now I can never find YouTube remember
when it was red for 90 years and then
all of a sudden they made a
white now can't find it um recently
watched come on babies recently watch
come on babies naturally I can't find
recently watched sighs very cool oh here
we go
new releases trending now TV shows
continue watching here it is uh weird
wonders of the world there's like 47
episodes of it I've watched all those
episodes by the way before I decided to
make violin sound better with spider
silk in goats
speaking of Netflix my Netflix special
comes out this summer man on fire um I
had shows in Oxnard this past week in
Oxnard California where is it hey I got
a question for yox nard where are you I
is so funny I would ask who was when
every show I had hundreds of people at
it and every and every time I asked hey
who's from here 14 people would clap um
not who where is it where are you who
lives here lots of buildings who lives
here so we did shows there and by the
way the staff and the management at the
Oxnard levity lot the levity Live Club
in Oxnard is maybe the best staff and
management I've ever dealt with
they're great if you want to go I'm sure
they're good with the customers too I
mean if you want to go to a comedy club
and they're great I don't know who
performs there all the time I know I did
this past weekend but man
great it's a great club so you they'll
take care of you uh if your knocks nard
check it out
but um and and and I'll tell you what
sometimes I do VIP like meet and greets
afterwards for like a few a few of the
people uh everybody there was it was
like the nicest to deal with like the
people there were great in Oxnard and
they were just so nice and pleasant and
not that drunk and just
appreciative I didn't know it was gonna
be like that but they were
awesome and uh and the security there
was awesome but I had to throw one girl
out man of the show and she was in the
front row and I went on stage first of
all my opener went up and he said yo you
got to be quiet and then my feature went
up and he said shut up to her like two
or three times so I said I was I said to
the security I was like just so you know
that lady right there is giving people
trouble if I say one thing to her you
got to throw her out because you already
been warned about four or five times so
I was in the middle of doing a bit about
you know something it was in the
beginning of my act and she goes dude
hey Chris like like it's just me and her
in the room together with no one else
she says hey Chris do the drunk girls a
bit and so I said I literally looked at
her I stopped what I was doing I looked
at her I said hey you got to go sorry
but you really gotta gotta go can you
throw her out please and everyone got
super weird because it was uncomfortable
I guess which I don't get uncomfortable
because I love it because you know
there's something nice about because I
know I'm making the show better I know
if she exits then everyone else gets to
watch the show they want to watch and
doesn't have some idiot yelling
out now
she was perplexed when I threw her out
she she was dumbfounded she wasn't angry
she was like what what what and I was
like yeah you got to go man my opener
three or four times
I think was more than that they were
like they told you to be quiet you just
got to go by and they it took three
minutes and I just stood there and it
was silent and it was it felt
good because I knew that after this the
show was going to be better and she she
was like looking at the people she was
with she was like you you're gonna come
with me right it was it is sad but I
don't give a dude you can't talk at
a comedy show because you're not the
comedian laugh and don't laugh that's it
two rules laugh don't laugh dude you
don't give me suggestion with my goddamn
jukebox first of all that drunk girls
bit is five years old I don't even know
it anymore if you to heckle you
get thrown out I don't know why people
don't know this man but this lady dude
she was you're gonna come with me right
oh it felt weird and good it
made me feel alive and then one lady
went with her but her other friends
didn't because they were like that
I paid to see this guy it was awesome
and it was weird for like ten minutes
after that I had to get back on track oh
man I wonder which I always wonder what
that person wakes up the next day
thinking cuz you know obviously she was
drunk but I wonder what she did you know
so many of them are like that wasn't
cool what he did I just asked him I just
gave him a suggestion it just don't you
can't do that man I have a feeling most
of the people who listened to this
podcast probably know not to do that but
dude I'm going to throw you out if you
if you're heckling that's what's going
to happen and here's the other thing too
it's it's always oh well no not always
but it's 95% of the time an attractive
woman it is and you can say oh that's
all cool or whatever but it is I'm the
comedian it's 95 percent of the time and
attractive
and I feel like it's because people
don't tell them no they don't
tell them they don't put them in their
place because they give them everything
be and-and-and-and guys say oh yeah ok
or no you can do what you want because
they want to that girl and and if
you come to my show and you do that by
cuz guess what I'm not gonna you
anyway you came with someone else and
I'm doing my job you got to go dude you
gotta go you know and and and and and
you know that goes back to the thing I
was saying earlier about how like be
respectful if you're gonna don't
don't
all of a sudden think you're hilarious
and make funny videos you got to
pay your dues you got to go onstage you
got to you got you got to be
funny you can't just be and then all of
a sudden be a realtor so if
you're going to a comedy show you got to
know how to be you can't just you
know guys telling you guys oh you're
great you're great you're amazing you're
amazing oh that's hilarious all you're
good oh you're yeah you can do
that of course you can yeah get away
with murder yeah you're hot because you
cleavage not you that's on you
dude that's on you to check yourself
it's hard as but it's still on you
dude but those guys are idiots
who do that those guys are morons
they got their own to work out but
that's on you to know how to be in a
room cuz you got brain cuz you
know what else even though you got
cleavage you got brain you guys you got
yours that's on you
every time I throw a chick out - I
always look at the dude cuz it's so fun
some guy was at one time I threw this
was a months ago I threw someone out I
thought the same thing a woman that was
you know fairly attractive heckled me
and um I actually don't remember what
she looked like but um a guy a guy goes
a guy said she I said you got go leave
and she started leaving and and I was
like how do you feel dude I was like you
probably feel really funny right now
because you uh you gotta like be on her
side and and even though you know
she's wrong but you got it cuz you're
her guy you know and I was
laughing at this I was saying this
on stage and it was totally weird but it
was totally funny because to me
and because I was like yeah is like you
feel so bunched up right now because
she's your girl and you got a stand by
her and you got to leave with her right
are you gonna stay even though you know
she's wrong you got to stand by I love
it dude I love it
dude if I brought a girl to a comedy
show and she heckled the comedian guess
what I'm doing
sittin I'm staying
see ya hey hey lady whoever I brought
you can either uber home or wait outside
of the comedy club club until the show's
over then I'll take you home
dude I I would love it I could be with
the girl for seven years she could be my
wife if she heckled by wait outside I'll
be done when the show's over
oh man I should have you know
have actually when people heckle I
should have United Airlines staff as my
security and they should just come in
and bash whoever's face in against an
armrest and then drag their limp body
doubt their limp bodies out United
dude remember remember that don't don't
lose win to that I wish somebody was
there to play the mission impossible
theme song um all right I'm gonna go on
Twitter I'm a look at these hashtags see
if anybody gamed the system or or if
they didn't uh-uh
here we go all right I'm looking at some
of these ones uh-oh somebody reminded me
about the Pepsi commercial Austin Lyon
at Austin B lion very cool good good job
but on the handle all right here's the
deal with the Pepsi commercial Pepsi
commercial was was actually the worst
commercial in history it was the number
one worst commercial in history um it
was horrible it was so ridiculous it was
so offensive I mean people are people
are dying cops white cops are beating up
black citizens and Kendall and and
they're Pro and people are protesting
all sorts of nowadays and
protesting real issues and these cops
are just kind of like watching and
Kendall Jenner hands this cop a Pepsi
and everything's all good and then
everyone cheers um but here's the deal
with the Pepsi commercial now Pepsi put
that commercial out there as if as if
they're a bunch of I mean
this is what this ad this relies talking
about earlier in this in the previous
episode these ads just make a better
ad you want people to buy Pepsi
just it's easy dude you it's easy
just get better commercials get you've
got too many people thinking about this
and then it turns into this
Oh we'll get kendall Jenner and she'll
give a cup of Pepsi and everything will
be okay huh
um but here's the thing about it
everyone went nuts this was the
worst move Pepsi not only apologized
which maybe they should have apologized
fine but they struck it they
said we're not going to air it anymore
you you make your bed you
air that commercial till it runs
dump until it's over you don't
disrespect me by by saying oh and
they're in their mind then they're in
their mind we'll take it down you
bitch-ass Pepsi um what show are you
watching on Netflix right now amber
Smith at amber Bop Pam ba and change it
I it was that uh wonders of the world or
whatever it was pretty was pretty good
even though they're talking about
violence for way too long uh so I got
another question here I get this one a
lot actually Joe Crawford at Joe o kroff
pretty good when you come into the UK I
don't know man the problem with the UK
and the and the overseas is you don't
make as much money the first time around
no matter how big you are they like to
be like well he's never played over here
technically so we can't you know we
don't know it's like everyone's got the
Internet all right the shows are all
over the place don't don't give me that
but I am going to Australia cuz I'm
just sucking it up I want to go um so
I'll be in UK soon I wanna I don't know
about soon but I want to go there I do
want to go there I just want you know
it's like I can pip when you can make
more money going to Milwaukee then you
can for going to London it's like it's a
little bit tougher so that's the reason
why I haven't been yet let's look here
[Music]
Lyonne update on Leo I don't think I
have an update on Leo I should text him
but I saw a man I went to his last
Instagram and like 48 people commented
on e he's got like two followers 48
people fall commented on its saws yeah
he's the French guy that I texted if you
don't remember what's the ugliest city
I've ever been to congratulations pot a
mythical Gabby mythical Gabrielle Purdy
not that's pretty that's okay I guess
ugliest city I've ever been to I would
say uh what's that one near Boston
Mansfield I think that's no man man's
field oh oh you know what is its where
the Basketball Hall of famous of Fame
where is that located I'm looking right
now uh Springfield Springfield
Massachusetts yep that's what the worst
city I've ever been to and I was
actually there um I was actually there
for the Basketball Hall of Fame inductee
and it was still blow my brains out
boring Jacksonville is not good either
Jacksonville Florida um but there's
probably so many worse cities I just
haven't been oh I'm just talking about
cities that I've been to bigger cities
that I've been to um everybody's asking
me about the United Airlines
this guy every now and then someone says
hey can you post a picture of you and
dr. Dre just look use your eyes user
looking I did already
Chris what do you think when you're
talking with a friend and someone tells
you to watch your language this is by at
Benjamin at Ben underscore yes
underscore Johnson Benjamin
Johnson um any rights gaming the system
yeah that's never do that if somebody
says watch the language I swear more
that's just horrible dude you're an
adult
you know you're an adult you can handle
that you can handle if I say you
can handle if I say you can handle
if I say and that's a real bad one
you know why you can handle that because
you're an adult um so and you know
there's worse things all right well so
look thanks for listening Maru de boys
and Masai dings uh I've got to do some
other Tings after this so I'm a little
bit busy sorry I can't stay longer than
an hour this time but it's been 57
minutes so far and I got a 10 to some
Tings okay um now let's recap don't sing
if you're not a singer again we talked
about that don't get a snake naturally
and watch that thing on the on the thing
on the Netflix is what I was talking
about about a the violence it's really
interesting wonders of the world and
yeah there'll be ads there will continue
to be ads and because trying to brag
trying to back up the Brinks truck okay
I'm trying to pile all this good ax
alright so if you're mad that I have for
for you know forty second ads on my
yeah change it use a different listen to
different podcasts guess what they'll be
hats on those alright so uh thank you
for listening
until the next ad until the next podcast
the the episode 12 that'll be the first
two episode 12 we ever did and that's it
don't forget to download the free square
cash app for iOS or Android now do that
because it's the best app for
transferring money from each other to
each other
I've got upcoming show dates coming up
Chris D'Elia calm uh Australia Arizona
um what do you call it Palm Beach West
Palm Beach tweet me at hashtag
congratulations pod and listen rate
review the show that will help and I'm
serious
you're probably like now I'm not gonna
do that but do that as soon as this ends
which is now just go rate and review the
show it's so easy and it helps me we are
now on stitcher so for all of you guys
that like to complain about all the
stuff that we're on and that we're not
on we're kind of on all of it alright
Google Play right stitcher iTunes um
YouTube we're on the youtubes one time
one time I had a guy say hey you got any
cool youtubes you got any new YouTube's
for me to watch um and it was funny and
the left all right thank you very much
you guys are snick gradual ations
podcast I'm Chris D'Elia
I'll see you when we see
[Music]